oh right Potter had your exams sale you
did
[Music]
first of all before we get into it
nobody freaked out I didn't cut my hair
it's just in a braid alright haha I know
I'm gonna get the comments otherwise but
okay I took a little break for reasons
that if you follow this channel should I
shouldn't have to explain before coming
back to do a wrap-up on the Harry Potter
movie revisit and because I've got one
last bit of business to do I need to
rank these because what's the point of
watching ten films if you're not gonna
then turn them into a top ten ranked
list hello what platform do you think
you're on welcome to YouTube where we
list stuff so I am now going to rank all
ten Harry Potter films released a date
that means all eight of the main series
and both fantastic beast movies so we'll
start at number 10 get the really
obvious one out of the way
bottom-of-the-barrel
fantastic beasts crimes of Grindelwald
this thing is just a mess it is not
completely devoid of positive qualities
and even the story being told could have
been a decent story if told in a
different way this is a muddled mess
that feels like the second draft of a
novel transposed directly as opposed to
something written for the screen it just
doesn't flow worth the dang the story is
clunky there are so many unanswered
questions and bizarre holes and too many
stories and plot lines try to just elbow
each other out of the way to did grab
screen time is that it's not good and so
let's move up to number 9 and you know
when I started this I was so certain it
was gonna be the other fantastic B's
movie but it's not and there's a lot of
people who have their nostalgia blinders
on who are gonna be real ticked at me in
a second Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone or Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone if you live in a
country where publishers think you're an
idiot hello so yeah look I understand
the significance of this film
I understand its importance and I don't
think it's a bad
film but I think it holds up the least
as far as how it was received at the
time and what it feels like going back
to watch it now
the effects are half-baked some of them
look honestly unfinished the
performances from the child actors are
decent as far as child actors go but
there's a lot of child actors and
they're young and the performances are
functional but everything they do and
every film after this is so much better
than this the adults are solid but even
they are still sort of getting their
heads around a lot of these characters
and end up doing much better work later
so taken in a vacuum perfectly fine film
but to me every single other Harry
Potter movie that came out after it
except for crimes or Grindelwald
exceeded it so it's good but everything
else stepped up its game and so that'll
put us at number eight which is
fantastic beasts and where to find them
and I while I didn't end up taking the
nice spot it came close I went back and
forth on this ultimately here's the
reason this sorted out the way that it
did the stuff about fantastic beasts
that I don't like kind of drives me nuts
the entire third act Colin Farrell's
character of graves some of the
world-building I think it is either not
good or is building a world I don't want
to spend time in which is infuriating
but the stuff that is good is quite good
the creatures themselves are wonderful
Newt Scamander
I didn't love him when I first saw him
but he's grown on me and I now really
like him Jacob is terrific Queenie is
quite good and there's a when this is
good it is so much fun the NIF lers
uh-huh I love the nefler and the baby
nibblers were about the only good thing
in crimes Grint of all but ultimately
the things that I like about this are
better than basically anything in
Sorcerer's Stone anything that I look at
from that film from that first Harry
Potter film that is
good was done better some of the stuff
that's done here is some of the best
stuff done here in this way or its
characters that were not done better in
the later sequel they're at their best
here and so this just edges out that to
come in at number eight moving up we get
to number seven Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets the acting from the
kids is getting better it's still got a
little ways to go but you can tell
they're settling into not only their
roles but their understanding the craft
of acting and what is involved in
delivering a believable performance
they're all getting better the adults
have settled into it and they're not
stumbling over some of the weird words
they have to say anymore which some of
them were first time around the effects
are miles better it's perhaps slightly
longer than it needs to be but that's
not the worst thing that I would say
about it it is pretty solid stuff all
right from here we move up to number six
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
Part 1 I feel like I like this movie
quite a bit more than a lot of people do
but immediately the stuff that comes in
the second half is way more cathartic
this is a movie of set up of build up
and why I do think it manages to give us
some kind of a three-act structure that
works well enough you can tell it's an
incomplete story and even though I feel
like it's well done that does bring it
down a bit plus the fact that a lot of
this is too dang dark you have trouble
seeing this
what's even on the screen at times which
is frustrating so again I enjoy it and
the high points are up there and like it
at this point all the actors the kids
especially know these parts so well that
you know they could do it in the sleep
but they're putting in a lot of work and
it comes off great it's just you know
again other stuff did it better it's
kind of the recurring thing going on
here
number 5 the other entry that folks are
gonna yell at before Harry Potter and
the Prisoner of Azkaban look it's my
favorite book in the series and the
movie is very good especially the new
direction that it takes be being willing
to make more
changes for the sake of flowing better
as a film there are way more than you
like because right now I'm in the
process of reading Prisoner of Azkaban
to my kid and we're all we're about
two-thirds of the way through it and way
more things got changed in the film
adaptation of this certainly versus the
first two not just like stuff cut stuff
outright changed and in my mind that's a
good thing because it means they were
tailoring and making adjustments that
have it flow better as a film cuz most
of the changes do I think feel
accomplished that but there are a couple
of things that it has working against it
the first is is that the structure of
the thing works better on the page than
it does on the screen because it kind of
climaxes and then has a very elongated
wrapping up and it tries for a second
climax and doesn't quite match the
earlier one so and that works better on
the page than it does on screen that's
one thing the other thing is they forgot
to plant a couple of seeds that they
then try and pay off there are things
that don't make sense about this movie
if you haven't read the book because the
movie itself fails to justify them it
like got just streamlined enough in some
areas but it went to streamline and
others to the point that you don't
understand certain elements if you have
not read the book and that's a big
problem for me you want more details you
can check out the review so we get now
into the top four and ordering the top
four was really hard because look can't
be honest I don't think there is a
perfect Harry Potter film all of them
have issues all of them have something
going on that I'm like that little bit
no hmm and sometimes it's a holdover
from the original book sometimes it's
something they chose to do or chose to
omit or chose to alter that was the
little mm but doing these last four was
really really tough coming up with the
order of these but this is what I came
up with number four Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire
I think the
performances are excellent in this I
think it has a great sense of fun and
adventure but then is able to bring the
darkness at the end the death of Cedric
and especially the impact that has on
Sid rooks father is painful for me to
watch and that is a testament to the
film and how well it depicts the impact
of that terrific performances across the
board from both the returning and the
new characters and there are a few
things in it that that do bring it down
a little bit the the dragon fight is
bigger and more elaborate goes on longer
than it should the the whole thing in
the maze is muddled and too dark and a
little anticlimactic it feels very
rushed that should have felt more like a
trial instead it just feels like a mild
inconvenience but this one's really good
and I like I said these last four
entries these were tough but moving up
from that one number three Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows Part two this
one is just pure catharsis going to see
this film and having it pay off seven
previous films and ten years worth of
filmmaking and performances and watching
these actors grow and and inhabit these
parts was just really fulfilling in a
way that honestly I don't think got
topped until Avengers endgame happened
it's just that level of feeling so
feeling everything so well delivered
seeing the payoffs for these characters
whether they are triumphant or tragic
and I just think that the roller coaster
ride that this thing takes you on is
really really solid stuff about the only
reason it didn't rank higher is because
it is effectively an entire film out of
what is normally just the third act of a
film so much like Deathly Hallows Part 1
was all set up and didn't quite have a
lot of payoff this is all paths without
a lot of setup which
when you judge it by a film as itself
it's it's kinda it's very back loaded
it's missing a lot of the stuff to build
up to it because it was all in a
different film and what I'm judging them
individually it's that sort of hair
splitting that ends up making the
difference so we arrive at number two
and of course anybody with a checklist
will realize what number one is when I
say what number two is but wait I'll get
there number two Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince I feel like I like
this one a lot more than most people do
almost book purists definitely there
were a lot of comments on my review
video that about it annoyed at how much
of the backstory for Voldemort got cut
the thing is maybe I'm alone in this I
found those parts of the book really
boring and way more intricate in detail
than they needed to be
I think those were smart cuts when it
came to making the film and one of the
things I really liked about this one
especially is you know coming off of the
back of the end of Goblet fire and then
order of the Phoenix this feels like it
recaptures something that was starting
to get lost actually I would argue even
was kind of lost in Prisoner of Azkaban
which was the school feel the classes
the high school friendships and it
brought that back in a way that I felt
was well integrated into the story as a
whole so it recaptured something that I
was starting to miss which I think was
especially important because if you
don't remind me this was why I started
falling in love with this world then
when the world gets threatened if I
forgotten what it was I loved that
threat doesn't mean as much and this
reminded me of that plus again amazing
performances across the board and I just
I just think this is a really smartly
adapted piece not perfectly they dropped
the ball on a few things they don't
properly bring across Harry's hero worse
of the half-blood Prince there's a
couple of things missing but I think
this is a really solid piece but it
doesn't take my number one and my number
one when I actually sat down to parse
this out surprised the ever-loving heck
out of me
and I'm still not even entirely sure I
understand why but I'm gonna put my
number one as Harry Potter in the order
of the Phoenix part of the reason you
need to understand why this is weird for
me is I don't like that book like very
much at all
I find that book infuriating to read and
I'm not looking forward to reading it to
my kid when we get to that one but the
changes that were made in adapting it
the alterations not narrative ly but
just the slight alterations some of
which just happen by the nature of the
medium of film versus a novel ie I don't
because I no longer have the omnipotent
narration that gets inside Harry's head
I don't have to read his stupid faulty
horrible thought processes anymore and
that makes a big difference because
Daniel Radcliffe can bring bring across
the emotions and things that Harry's
feeling but I don't have to get bogged
down a page after page after page of him
rationalizing being a jerk to everybody
I get that that's what he's doing but to
have to read his thought processes was
infuriating and simply removing that
that makes a big difference and other
little tweaks little streamlines the
things to blue visually it's got a blue
filter laid over it that it did not need
but it is a really strong piece of
adaptation it makes smart choices and
make smart cuts it makes smart
alterations and I think might just
flat-out be one of the strongest films
in the series and if not the strongest
as a film unto itself and I'm gonna put
it at number one which I would not have
called so that's my ranking for these
films I'm sure yours is different
I'm sure many of you have already typed
out why I'm wrong but whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it there's a
bunch of stuff to do as well because
there's buttons and links this entire
revisit of Harry Potter was in fact
sponsored by a patreon supporter you can
support me on patreon as well there's a
link down in the description plus links
to other things that I do and you can
follow me on etcetera etc etc but you
also don't have to do any of that
because at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
there was a dog right there who has been
snoring and I wish I knew if it was loud
enough that the mic picked it up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]